une
Ma mère et mon père
Il y a ma sœur et mon frère
Chérie, tu sais que je suis
Avec toi, reviens de
Mon voyage
Ma mère et mon père sont là, ma sœur et mon frère sont là
Chérie, tu sais que je suis
Avec toi, reviens de
Mes voyages reviennent de
Mon voyage et la distance m'ont brisé la mâchoire, ô Qatar, ma vie
Et la distance
Nous l'avons coupé, Qatar
Aya
Oh oh oh
Oh, le Qatar
Al-Saï
Reviens, Qatari
Délégations et esprit de Minya
Malawi avant
Suha, Sayut, Madad, Madad, Ya
Janawi, Madad, Madad, Janawi et les précieux Arabes
Chère Egypte, chère Palestine
Alia et l'Algérie qui m'est chère et la Tunisie
C'est précieux pour moi, oh, et le Maroc m'est précieux, alors abandonne
Chère France
Sur toi, toi
Oh oh oh
Oh, le Qatar
Sud